well wait miley you saw it those first
two pitches were
cutters in on the hands and that's what
he's going to try to do against these
cubs hitters a lot of right-handed
batters in this lineup so look for him
to try to establish
that inside part of the plate no score
just underway first meeting between
these old rivals three and two the pitch
to brian
and that ball's hammered to left that
one towards the corner and that ball is
gone
home run chris bryant he'll touch them
all
number seven on the year and the cubs
jump out one to nothing a laser to left
for kb
well no surprise when you looked at this
matchup with what kb has
been doing this year what he's done
against left-handed pitching when he's
done in this ballpark you kind of liked
his chances
they're up against jake arrieta he's the
starting pitcher for the cubs tonight
sinkers mostly with the fastball at 91 a
lot of cutters slot slash slider curve
and a chain jump you look to watch and
see if a guy stays with the adjustment
that he has made
opposite way horner
leaps and can't make the catch bottle
never broke stride
he jogs into second base
a double to left field and the reds have
the tying run in scoring position
warner looked like he was there looks
like he just jumped to the side of the
ball
that fence defenseless things in your
head
that one hit hard rizzo picks it up
arietta gets over
and they get mustaches jake pitches
around a two out double end of one in
cincinnati it's one nothing
two hits a couple of walks continues
great job of making contact and just
knowing the strike so it slices that one
the other way and there's a base hit
that's a matt duffy at bat right there
isn't it
got one line to right and that one is
over the head of castellanos
duffy to third he'll stop there marizna
cruises into second
now nico becomes the key man in the
inning you've got one away second and
third and the pitcher on deck now the
3-2
bouncing ball towards short this will
score run the throw to first is in time
and duffy comes in to score suarez was
playing back at short cubs get the run
in
it is now two to nothing
petra sold for one flied to left
and that one hit hard and past the
lunging mustache down the line and into
the corner
and so wilson contreras with a double
[Applause]
it's two nothing it's the third inning
at a miss
wade miley's first k
comes at the expense of javier baez and
that's a biggie with men at second and
third now the infield can move back
to short longer throw
motto with the reach stays on
and miley strands a pair
bode shades heavy behind second
laid away
grounded left side loved by duffy second
one first
not in time miley scores and the reds on
the board it's two to one
joey vada was double to left shift is on
the lead
and that one is shot out of a cannon to
right field a towering home run for joey
motto number 300 and the reds take a 3-2
lead
a no doubter as joseph daniel bottle
becomes the third man in franchise
history with 300 big flocks
guys are certainly happy for joy
congratulations joy
this has got to be a curtain call right
of course these fans want it he's going
to give it
juarez now over his last 26.
after his first and bat fly out the 1-0
pitch and that's a ball in the air crush
to center mariznick back
gone
hey eugenio suarez back on track as he
goes straight away and solves the lead
4-2
this reds team just
kills opposing pitching particularly at
great american ballpark runner fakes
senzelle shoots one a deep left field
horner breaks back and that's gone
second homer of the inning
a two-run laser
second time through the order the reds
are five for seven with three home runs
tonight wow second time through tonight
five for seven with three homers here's
joey votto
who has doubled and homer
grounded over the lead big welfare ball
miley scores pitbulls off the side
a rip up to third late stop sign put up
red light for castellanos and rbi double
joey votto three for three with three
extra base knots here's where you don't
want to get big right down five you need
traffic 02 now
and that one is lined right back up the
middle in a base hit contreras his
second hit
pj manville's heading out with rossi
yeah clearly something bothering him
because he didn't even wait for them to
meet him at first base he just i'm done
this is not good
from the way he was pointing it was like
right at the attachment of his
hamstring bobby baez and francisco
lindor came up together
that's a fair ball mustache long throw
on two hops and it's there to beat fires
and bias
argues the play
what a throw
the loose moose
steal retired the first four he faced
three with strikeouts
and that one is rocked bodie fires home
farmer slides safe the tag missed by
walters
no bueno jesse winkers out of the game
tomas vera athletic trainer
talking to winker seems to be clutching
at the small of his back on the right
side he's been lifted mark payton is in
that ball's ripped out towards left
center
and that one will take a bounce and hop
off the wall peyton will collect it
racing around third and coming in to
score is so guard bryant's got another
extra base hit it's an rbi double and
the cubs get a run back
it's 8-3
he said you know when i was wide i did
some damage too
and maybe i'll end up going wide again
so i think it's you're constantly
searching in this game
suarez not able to make the play bryant
comes across
and now it's 8-4
crushed to deep left payton
makes the catch sogar tag at third
attack from second
throw in
taken in by bustaka sac fly rbi
as sogard scores it's a three-run game
tying run still bats but two outs right
he comes set three and two
inside ball four and he walks in a run
and the cubs are within two
and you gotta mean that'll mean the
bullpen door will swing open
for tj antone third straight batter
bases loaded two outs to see a
two-strike count
each of the last two walked
0-2
grounded left side gobbled mustache sets
his feet and the reds win it
tj antone's first career save he turns
the trick on three pitches